[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were going to be giving a full breakdown
of the newly released birds-of-prey
trailer that was just dropped today by
Warner Brothers throughout this video
I'm gonna be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the first
look and how it lines up with the leaks
that we've had on the film over the past
month because of this there will be some
spoilers so if you don't want anything
about the phone potentially ruined for
you then I highly suggest that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into a breakdown of
the birds of prey trail okay so if we
just rewind the trailer to the first
shot there will actually see Paulie
Quinn and Cassandra Cain walking along
the street now apparently in the leaks
they team up right near the start of the
phone because Cassandra's Kane steals
something from Black Mask and yeah
they're just kind of a nice little team
in Gotham we then see em Black Canary in
black masks Club and there's a lot of
hands in black mask Club I don't know
why apparently just has a hand fish and
but yeah we can see the first ones of
them here
no one gives two shits who we are okay
so we did find out in the leaks that
Joker and Harley Quinn broke up and
there was behind the scenes shot of
Joker kicking Harley Quinn out of the
house and and I don't know if it was
Jared Leto you couldn't see because
there was something obscuring his face
I'm guessing not because he's a very
expensive actor to get hold of for a
five second part of the film but they've
broken up and she's kind of out on her
own doing her own thing yeah
[Music]
she's going through a whole Britney in
the 2000s phase of like cutting her hair
okay so the did break up yeah I haven't
actually watched this trailer all the
way through I'm just kind of reacting it
to give my fresh feelings on it but yeah
she's clearly not taking the break-up
well as she stuck a knife in a picture
of him okay if we go back there and we
can actually see but canary one of her
big powers is sort of her voice and is a
very very huge force that can kind of
not keep people back it can do damage to
things and we can see that when she's
singing here that it is shaking that
martini glass and so yeah nice little
nice little tease there what's gonna
happen there's Renee Montoya um who is
basically in the GCPD we can see a
walking along here she apparently in the
leaks knows that the GCPD cannot stop
black mask because everyone's kind of
under his wallet and so she breaks away
from it and joins the birds of prey
there's Huntress with a classic crossbow
[Music]
black mask without his mask there and
he's also shown that he's very ruthless
I do quite like this costume design um
but yeah I do want to see him with the
mask now according to the leaks whether
these these are true or not you know
take it with a pinch of salt he does get
his mask in the film and it gets burned
into his face after an explosion and
that's kind of how he gets the name but
for the majority of the movie he'll be
not he'll be basically you McGregor you
don't pay for you McGregor and not show
his face and now we could see Harley
Quinn feeding bud or Louie and food this
was in one of the leaks as well
basically Cassandra Cain and Hollie team
up together and the first thing I do is
get food for their hyena and now we can
see them teamed up so black masks goons
are actually out on the hunt for
Cassandra Cain and because she stole
something from Black Mask and she finds
basically defense with Harley Quinn and
these are the guys going against her and
Huntress 2 is initially out to kind of
kill her but she apparently discovers
something about her past that links to
black mask and turns against him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay and it looks like black mask is
kind of basically getting a Halle quina
perform
I hope that is a Marilyn Monroe
reference and also a Madonna one as well
for material girl if it is then yeah
that move this is going to borne me
around just this one shot if the rest of
the movie is how it looks so far I'm a
bit funny on it but yeah nice little
Easter Egg there and I just realized
there's loads of hands around her again
yet so it's this hand aesthetic that's
continuing through the trailer
apparently that guy with the scars on
his face that might be Victor Zsasz so
Victor Zsasz is a Batman villain that
when he makes a kill he cook he cuts
himself that puts a scar into his face
and if that is him then yeah that's a
nice little nice little Easter egg there
[Music]
again with the material guilt so they
definitely are parroting that and that's
gonna be in black mask's Club I'm
guessing but it's just a nice little
image done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that looks like Halle Quinn's
committing a lot of crimes going about
sort of I think that might be a Gotham
police officer and so she's clearly
broken in they're getting something out
don't know what it is thanks for
clicking the video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay in there we got a first real looker
Cassandra Cain and she's very different
from the source material in that she's
sort of a mute child who's actually a
master martial artist her parents were
assassins and they raised her to be able
to basically read body language and that
makes her a better fighter because you
know if someone's speaking to you you
can understand what they're saying if
someone's giving away their body
language in a fight you can just
completely determine what they're going
to do and then block it defend and then
take them down it doesn't look like that
going with that which is disappointing
but guess we'll have to see and that's
the trailer honestly at the moment I'm
very very cautious about this film it
really could go one of two ways so I'm
going in with tempered expectations over
this emancipation sorry Baba totally
this seems really all over the place and
more in line with the Suicide Squad that
whilst I enjoyed didn't really feel like
a good direction for DC to be taking in
a universe now they have seemed to take
steps towards other properties and ideas
with Joker coming out this Friday and it
seems like they are really struggling to
decide what the best way to take their
universe is this is also getting a
February release which is where most
movies go to die so it seems a bit like
DC don't have that much confidence in
the overall peace now it may still be
good but I really hope that 2020 is the
air that DC kind of streamlined their
universe a bit more I used to absolutely
love Harley Quinn and even have a tattoo
of her but over the last couple of years
my interest is slowly waned with the
constant updates and I personally feel a
too far removed from the pauldini
version that I fell in love with this
could be a good film and I hope it's not
the one to break the streak that DC are
on at the moment
but just don't know something about this
seems a little off but maybe it's not
for me like Warner Brothers are clearly
going after a female audience with this
and hey if girls find it empowering then
Who am I to say that it's not right it's
just that if this is the case and it is
not for me then I think my opinion on it
is justified at least who knows it may
be gray but I guess we will see in
February now obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the trailer and if you
agree with me or not comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of the news that
the chameleon will be appearing as the
villain in spider-man 3 I break down the
full scoop as well as the news that she
Hulk will be cameo in before her Disney
Plus debut so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
content so hopefully I see you over
there after this well so just wanna let
you know that we're currently giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning it's
the like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the birds-of-prey trailer in
the comment section below the winner
will be chosen at random on October the
15th and the blue arrow be shipped out
from the intricate surprise so best of
luck to everyone who takes channel 4
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you